Transformers rise of the beasts takes a
lot of big swings but saves its most
jaw-dropping reveal for the end when it
seems to set up the crossover fans have
likely been dreaming of warning spoilers
for Rise of the beasts ahead in the
rankings of absolutely wild endings in
the Transformers movies the latest
installment rise of the beasts just took
pole position for the franchise's best
Cliffhanger to date particularly for
those that know their Golden Era
Saturday morning cartoons the end gets
going as usual with the autobot's
rule-abiding leader Optimus Prime having
some closing words to roll us out only
this time accompanied by the hero of the
hour Noah Diaz it's a great team effort
but it turns out that neither of them
can match the almighty mic drop of actor
Michael Kelly conducting what looks to
be a job interview with Noah Kelly
turning up minutes before the credits
should have made alarm bells ring
instantly it turns out that this isn't
just any old job interview and Noah's
potential employer already knows
everything about him more importantly he
knows what happened in Peru which larger
than Life characters he allied with and
that his sick brother's medical bills
will be covered for the foreseeable
future and knowing is half the battle
that's right Noah has just been offered
a position to work with the GI Joe quite
literally opening the secret door for
one massive toy based Hasbro property to
collide with another but how who signed
off on this what will happen when the
autobot's Decepticons Joes and Cobra
come face to face as it turns out it's
been something Paramount was reluctant
to embark on for some time speaking to
uprox about the potential crossover in
2021 producer Lorenzo de bonaventura
explained every regime that's been at
Paramount is against it because it's
taking two franchises and making them
one but I think it's inevitable
one fan in particular has been pretty
vocal about the idea and went straight
to the top to ask why this hadn't come
about de bonaventura revealed Stephen
cable who's directing Transformers right
now is a huge GI Joe fan too and he was
like why aren't you doing that everyone
was like well try to make a Transformers
movie really good then we'll talk about
that with rise of the beasts going all
Nick Fury on us just what would a
Transformers GI Joe crossover film look
like the Transformers and Joes have
crossed paths plenty of times with their
first encounter going back to 1986 in
comic book form that Medium is where
most of their epic standoffs have
occurred in fact many of their
altercations followed the routine method
of good guys from both sides
misunderstanding each other at first and
then aligning with one another to stop a
joint threat this has led to moments
like the death and Revival of Bumblebee
Cobra having a Cybertron connection and
the Earth being a planet-sized
Transformer named Atlas such high drama
stories would undoubtedly be great for
fans to see and if this crossover does
come to pass it could also be a huge
benefit for the half of this team up
that has struggled to find a solid
foothold in theaters while the
Transformers franchise has basked in its
box office billions the GI Joe film
franchise has only made 715 million
dollars over the three live-action films
since 2009. if the Paramount top dogs
believe Stephen Caple has got the touch
after rise of the beasts he could be
saving more worlds than one with
Transformers GI Joe the Joes might just
come back and win the battle after all
[Music]
no no